(gentle instrumental music)
- [Narrator] Most cathedrals have been
built to withstand the test
of time, but not this one.
Welcome to the Easter
Arches of Sicily, Italy.
But come quick, they won't last.
Every Easter, the town of
San Biagio in Sicily, Italy,
is home to a cathedral made out
of breads, cereals, and pastas.
Visitors are able to wander
through the Arches of Bread
and enjoy the detailed designs up close.
The structure is created by locals,
and takes around three
months to construct.
The origins of this tradition date back
to ancient times when visiting royals
expected to be greeted
with grand displays.
San Biagio was a town
of mostly poor farmers,
so they used what they had: bread.
In the mid 18th century the tradition
became a celebration of Easter.
Although the appetizing
displays aren't edible,
a walk through the Arches of Bread
is a testament to the city's long history
and the artistic
capabilities of its citizens.
(electronic dinging)